hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com today we're going to
be going over a fun trap in the vienna
game which starts out with e4
e5
knight c3 and then after they mirror us
with knight c6 we're going to play
bishop c4 attacking the weak f7 square
early on now most common is just to play
knight to f6 but they could mirror us as
well and play bishop to c5 attacking our
weak square on f2 makes a lot of sense
and if they do this we're going to play
queen g4
now a lot of players won't play g6 in
this spot because if they do play g6
they like they like to fee and cater
their bishop here to g7
and since their bishop's already out
here they may not decide to do that they
could also try something pretty crazy uh
you know knight to d4 try to be pretty
aggressive but then we can just come up
here take on g7 attack their rook here
uh they could put us in check but then
we move over if they try to you know
gobble up
our rook here they are going to lose
so that they're going to have to try
something else maybe potentially queen
f6 in this spot but then we could just
take that they take ours and then we
take their material right here and we
are up in material after the rook to g8
pawn to g3
you can see we are already up in
material
if we come back though we are going to
be looking at the variation where
instead of playing g6 or
2d4 they're gonna play queen f6 you can
see their queen and their bishop are
both eyeing down our pawn on f2 which is
a huge weakness for us because the king
is the only piece that's defending it
and we're not even going to consider
that right now instead we're going to
play the move knight to d5 and this is
the game that we're going to look at it
has a 69 win rate so if you can actually
play this against your opponent you are
going to have a fun time now if you look
at and say can't they just play queen to
f2
absolutely they can but the problem is
it's very difficult for black to
capitalize on this and white's going to
have a very good game so first let's
look at what white's going to do well
they only have one option that's to play
king 2 d1
and now where does
black continue to because we have so
many threats we have the threat of
knight to c7 check forking the rook on
a8
we have the threats of queen to g7
preparing to take this rook on h8 and
yes this bishop and the queen did attack
on f2 but after that they can't really
do anything else the queen can't come to
f1 it's being protected by the light
squared bishop it can't come to e1
because
black doesn't have control of the e1
square except the queen
can't take this knight here can't take
the pawn on g2 right away because the
queen is protected so how do they
continue well let's look at a few
options one let's say they start with g6
but if they move g6 we can now introduce
an additional threat we can play knight
h3 attacking their queen
and where do they go from here well if
they tried something like d6 and say hey
you can take my queen but then i can
just take your queen the problem why
that's not going to work for black is we
can now take with our knight and then
when they take our queen with their
bishop we can now take with our knights
now they can castle on the queen side
but you can see come over we have four
minor pieces they have three minor
pieces they did lose that exchange but
there's just no good square for them to
go to so let's come back what if they
don't play
g6 what if instead they play king to d8
remember they have to worry about so
many threats one of those threats is
knight to c7 forking the king and
attacking the rook on a8
but now we can just play queen takes on
g7
they could come down to
d4 this is definitely an option
but now we can go ahead and take on
h8
because our queen is no longer
protecting the g2 square they can swing
over and take on g2 but now we can play
the move knight to e3 which is such a
brilliant move as you really study the
situation and they can't take our rook
because if they take our rook on h1 we
can now take on g8 and this is going to
be checkmate there's no way for them to
stop the mating threats that we have
does take a few moves for us to get
there but eventually it is going to be
checkmate so if we come back we
recognize that that's not going to work
they can't take with their queen on h1
so how do they really respond after we
play knight to e3 because remember their
queen is under attack so the other
option is to play queen g6
they need to protect that knight on
g8 but now we just play c3 attacking
that knight kicking that away
they move the knight away we can just
take it with our bishop they take with
their pawn then we play knight to e2
and you can see
we have a fine game when we're up in the
material we've taken one of their rooks
we both have three minor pieces this is
going to be a pretty easy win for
white
now if we come back what if they don't
play king 2 d8 early on what if instead
they play
uh bishop to f eight
they try to protect that pawn on g7 well
as you can imagine we have too many
threats so we played knight c7 check and
after they play king d8 we just take
their rook on a8
and they're
in a losing position white should have a
pretty easy game from here now the best
move for black in this position after we
play king to d1 is to play the move king
f8
now similar to once they play g6 we're
going to be playing knight to h3
and you can see that the queen is under
attack so how do they defend it
you can't really come along this f file
there's no safe squares for it it can't
come to g3 or h4 both of those are under
attack
so there's a few options one we already
looked at why it's not going to work if
they play d6 because then we just take
their queen they take our queen and then
we take with our knights and they lose a
minor piece
okay well what happens if they play
queen
d4
well now we can just play d3 protecting
both our bishop and our pawn right here
and then the next move we have the move
c3
again black's in a tough spot they don't
really have anywhere to go
so they could play the best move but
it's still tough for them and that is h5
so yes it's not going to work if they
play d6 and attack our queen with their
bishop but h5
does make some sense here because if we
take their queen now they can just take
with their pawn
but we can play g5
now if they play f6 we play
queen g6
they need to continue attacking rook to
h6 attacking our queen but then we have
the brilliant move of knight to f4 and
this is kind of the beauty of
all the different moves and they just
don't have any way to defend properly
they can't take with their pawn you can
probably see this is just checkmate
right away so that's kind of a hidden
checkmate trap that we have here they
can't do that so that's one option they
have to worry about the other option is
let's say they take with their rook on
g6
well now we can first take with our
knight we don't have to take their queen
first we can first take their rook
check
after the king comes to e8 now we can
take their queen after bishop takes on
f2 the exchange we can take their knight
on g8 and you can see we're up in
material in the spot we capture that
additional rook this should be a pretty
easy game
for us
now the only other option that they have
after we played knight to f4 they could
try pawn d5 opening up for their light
square bishop to get involved into the
game yes it does sacrifice a pawn and
material but really they're in a tough
spot and sometimes you have to give up
material to make sure that you don't
have a position that completely
collapses so after we take on d5 with
our bishop they can bring their bishop
down to g4 it's still not going to work
though white's going to have a
much better game plan than black queen
takes on a g4 pawn takes
and now knight e6 checks you can see all
the threats that we have here
king 2e7 now our knight takes on f2
capturing their queen they take our
knight on f2
and then we take the pawn on g7 and you
can see we are up in material here as
well
now while we're only up a pawning
material in this spot they had to play
perfectly
just to be down in material with their
king completely
exposed so definitely a fun fun trap uh
if you get the opportunity to play it in
the vienna game but thank you guys so
much for watching hopefully you enjoyed
it let me know if you have thoughts on
this video or anything else you would
like to see and i'll see you guys next
time